[موسيقى]
ابنة حزينة
تقول وداعها الأخير قبل أن
يحترق جسد والدها إلى رماد
في محرقة الجثث الكهربائية هذه
[موسيقى
]. تقول الابنة التي طلبت
الحفاظ على هويتها أن تظل سرية خلال هذا
الوقت العاطفي إنها لن تنسى أبدًا
كيف انهار بين ذراعيه  قبل ليلة
من معاناتها من مرض الطمع 19 ،
بدأت مستويات الأكسجين لدى والدها في الانخفاض
بعد مكالمات محمومة ، اتصل زميل لها
مع سرينيفاس بي في
التي تقود جناح الشباب في
حزب سياسي معارض
لما كان معظم سكان دلهي
يبحثون يائسين عن
أسطوانة أكسجين تم
توصيلها قريبًا بواسطة  فريقه إلى منزلها
ولكن في وقت لاحق من تلك الليلة عندما
نفد الأكسجين من الأسطوانة
نفد والدها أنفاسه ،
كان بإمكانه أن ينقذ الأب بسهولة
إما أنه سيحصل على
الأكسجين ، وكان بإمكانه الحصول على سرير كان بإمكانه
الحصول على سرير العناية المركزة الذي
يمكنه الحصول عليه  أنقذت والدها بسهولة
بمفرده وهشًا وغطت 19 إيجابية
، طلبت من سرينيفاس المساعدة في حرق جسده
وفعل ذلك عن طيب خاطر مع فريقه
بينما كان غير مرغوب فيه  أمي
وشقيق لا عزاء
له يعيش في الخارج ينظران إلى أن
سرينيفاس قد نام بالكاد
مرحبًا ، الهاتف لا يتوقف عن الرنين ، مرحبًا
الأقارب اليائسون يطلبون المساعدة في
الأسرة ، والأدوية
والأكسجين يتصلون طوال الليل في الساعة 2 صباحًا في
الساعة 3 صباحًا وهم يتسولون للحصول على كمية صغيرة من الأكسجين
يقول الأسطوانة ،
لكن يجب عليه التحمل على الرغم
من انتقادات مسؤول حكومي هندي
بأن هذه كلها خدعة علاقات عامة ،
لكن في الوقت الذي
لا تزال فيه الحكومة تعمل معًا ، قام
الآلاف في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بالتواصل
مع
مجموعته للمساعدة في
كثير من الأحيان  صرخات في الليل لا أستطيع النوم في
الليل ،
لقد رأينا الكثير من الحالات المحزنة
التي تركها الآباء وراءهم أطفالًا صغارًا
يعتنون بهم ، وقد طلب
من طاقم الدعم الخاص به في غرفة الحرب
المساعدة في إعطاء الأولوية للشرطة من خلال
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
التي يتم إعادة توجيهها بعد ذلك  إلى الفرق في
دلهي والولايات في جميع أنحاء
الهند
، نفصل بين أدوية بلازما السرير وطلبات العناية المركزة
هنا ونحيلها إلى فرقنا.
يقطع
محادثتنا أب يتوسل للحصول على أسطوانة أكسجين لفريق
ابنه البالغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات ،
انطلق سرينيفاس مع أسطوانة
، ينتظر الأستاذ الجامعي الضعيف بشكل واضح ألو
كومار خارج منزله
لخط حياة ابنه يطلب منا أن
نحافظ على بعض المسافة
فهو منحني  إيجابي إنه
يخدم الإنسانية ، لم يسألني عن
الحزب السياسي الذي
أؤيده أو ألقي به ، فهذه هي الطريقة التي
يجب أن يساعد بها الناس
داخل منزله طفله الصغير المحشو
تحت أغطية مع مقياس تأكسج نبضي مثبت
في إصبع قدمه
يتنفس بشكل سطحي من خلال قناع أكسجين
كل  يمثل اليوم تحديًا جديدًا لهؤلاء
الأشخاص ،
فإن مواردهم محدودة ولكن
التوقعات
ليست أنا ، لقد رأيت ثلاثة أشخاص
من نفس العائلة يموتون أمام عيني
العديد من المرضى لا يتلقون العلاج في الوقت
الذي يحطم
قلبي ويقول
بقلب حزين ولكن  عاقلة العزم
شكرا جزيلا لك يعود إلى العمل سي إن إن
نيودلهي